BRADY HARAN: I want to deal with
a number that must be the
most requested so far on
Numberphile, and that is 301.
Now, for those of you who don't
pay much attention to
the YouTube view counters, you
might wonder what the big deal
is with 301, and let
me tell you.
When a new video is uploaded,
and if it's quite a popular
one, you'll quickly see the view
counter rise and rise and
rise, and then it will get to
301, and it will freeze.
And it will stay on 301 for a
day, maybe half a day, and
then it will start counting to
higher numbers as usual.
Now, a lot of people have been
very mystified by this, and
have asked us to check it out.
TED HAMILTON: I'm Ted Hamilton,
I'm a product
manager for YouTube Analytics.
BRADY HARAN: So there you go.
I've got in touch with the
people who actually count the
YouTube views.
TED HAMILTON: That is correct.
Well, we actually have
the computers do it.
We don't count them ourselves,
but yes.
BRADY HARAN: So before we get
to this whole 301 malarkey,
what is a view on YouTube?
I've always wondered.
is someone just pressing play
counting as a view?
TED HAMILTON: Well, that's
actually a bit
of a YouTube secret.
A view should be a video
playback that was requested by
an actual user who got what they
were intending to get and
had a good user experience.
We think of views as a currency,
and therefore we
have to make a significant
effort to eliminate
counterfeit views,
if you will.
BRADY HARAN: Now, I know that
all sounds a bit mysterious,
and we will come back to it
later on in the video, but
let's crack on with
this 301 figure.
And you're going to find out
counterfeit views actually
have a bit to do with it.
But the next thing we need to
realize is when you watch any
video, like this one for
example, you're probably not
all watching it from
the same server.
It gets distributed all
around the world.
TED HAMILTON: So there is
the original, which
you will have uploaded.
Or I guess by the time you
are watching this,
have already uploaded.
Then this gets, what
do you call it?
Cached in different locations,
so that when you make a
request for a video, it doesn't
need to travel all the
way from London over to
California and say OK, send me
back all of these bytes
way back here.
BRADY HARAN: So with multiple
copies of the video all around
the world, counting the views
starts to get a little bit
more complicated.
TED HAMILTON: Here's you
at your computer
watching the video.
If you make a request to this
server, this server is going
to give you the video, right?
And at the same time, this
server is going to write a
little message to a log.
It's just one line in a log.
Every once in awhile, we collect
all of these logs.
So we'll ship this thing in
from central Europe, or
whatever into the central log
collection area, aggregate
them all together, and then go
through and count them up.
BRADY HARAN: Well OK, that seems
simple enough, but it
doesn't explain why the
view counter freezes.
TED HAMILTON: Views, as
mentioned, are a currency.
When you have a video with a
very small amount of views,
then you don't need to
be too careful about
what that view was.
However, once it gets to be
above 300 and beyond, this
currency we really need to
verify and make sure that the
number is what it
purports to be.
So this means that we have to
go through a statistical
verification process, and that
statistical verification
process actually takes
some time.
And thus we go from incrementing
one by one to
then saying, OK, now we're
incrementing in batch, and all
of these views that have been
added on have been verified by
YouTube to be real views.
We are preventing things like
bots to go in and add a bunch
of views to a video.
Or we are preventing something
that may have perhaps misled
someone into watching a video.
Say you had a title that was
completely misleading, and a
thumbnail that was completely
misleading, and people
actually went on there and just
viewed for a few seconds,
and then left.
If you see that enough times,
it a fair enough indicator
that something was wrong there,
so that we might not
authorize all of those to
be legitimate views.
BRADY HARAN: All right, then.
They're verifying the numbers.
They're checking everything.
I guess we probably could
have guessed that.
But why 301?
TED HAMILTON: I was not there
when the decision was made,
but at some point the decision
was made that we need to draw
a line between what is innocuous
and the database can
handle, and what is all of a
sudden serious business.
The proportion was calculated to
be at about 300, that this
is the portion that we
need to take care of.
But the formula that we use to
arrive at 300, I don't know if
anyone actually knows that.
BRADY HARAN: Well, OK.
They drew a line in the sand.
It was kind of arbitrary.
They wanted to differentiate
between people just sharing
their home movies and the videos
that are more popular,
the ones that are a
bit more serious.
The ones that need scrutiny.
But that was 300.
The view counter
freezes at 301.
What's going on here?
Is there a reason?
TED HAMILTON: Yeah,
there is a reason.
And the reason was the number
300 was chosen.
And when someone's writing code,
they need to put the
logic in the code that says
where you should stop, or
where you should, if one
condition is true,
you go to the left.
And the other condition is true,
you go to the right.
Now, this condition can
be written like this.
If the view count is less than
300, then go ahead and add one
to the view count.
Otherwise, go to x where x is
our much more complicated view
count pipeline.
However, what actually got
written was not this, but if
view count is less than or equal
to 300, then increment
the view count.
So what this means is if the
view count is at 300, this
says is the view count less
than or equal to 300?
Yes, it is.
Let me add one.
So then you end up at 301.
BRADY HARAN: Let me recap
what's going on here.
The code which is controlling
where this view counter
freezes contains a less
than or equal to sign.
So that means when a new early
view comes along, it's checked
against the code.
Say the overall view count
on the database is 299.
OK, then.
We'll let another one on.
Here comes another view.
Now the view count is 300.
That isn't less than 300,
but it is equal to 300.
So the code lets another view
jump onto the total.
Now we're at 301, and when
another view comes along, it's
not less than 300, but it's also
not equal to 300 anymore,
and the door is shut.
There are going to be no more
views added to the publicly
visible count until YouTube
have done their checks.
And that will take half
a day to a day.
Then of course, all the extra
views that have been counted
in the interim all pile
onto the total.
Nothing's missed.
At least that's what I'm told.
TED HAMILTON: Yeah, so whoever
wrote this code probably did
not realize the magnitude
of what they were doing.
View counts have been around
since the beginning of
YouTube, and who was to know
what YouTube would become.
So yeah, that was actually a
rather monumental second of
time in San Bruno, California,
when a coder decided to write
that logic in.
It is now one of the
idiosyncrasies of YouTube.
BRADY HARAN: Now, I can hear
some of you screaming at your
computer screens.
The view count doesn't
stop at 301.
Sometimes it stops at
302, or 305, or 310.
What's going on there?
There's an explanation for that,
too, and that comes back
to how I was saying the videos
are shared around servers all
across the world.
So here's what's
going on there.
Views are coming in from the
logs at the different videos,
the different places
around the world.
And they're coming to this
central database.
And we know the door's going
to be shut at 301, we just
explained that a minute ago.
But what happens if views are
coming in at the same time?
Someone watched it in Africa at
the exact same time someone
watched in Europe.
Now we've got multiple
views coming in.
Checking if they're allowed to
join the count, yes they are.
It's less than or
equal to 300.
So they all pile on
at the same time.
Now when a new view comes
along, sorry,
we're closed for business.
But because of that simultaneous
update, a few
extra views were able
to sneak on.
TED HAMILTON: We get asked
about it all the time.
I wouldn't say that it causes
angst, but it's certainly, I
would classify it more
as an annoyance.
You can go and see a very
popular video, and you look
and you'll see that it has 2,000
likes and 300 views.
That's a little bit
interesting.
The issue there is that we don't
put the likes through
the same rigor, same
rigorous process.
And likes are far fewer in
magnitude, so our systems can
handle them more easily.
But the views do freeze, and it
can result in some awkward
situations.
But that actually results in
terrific videos like this, so.
BRADY HARAN: I did speak to Ted
for maybe 45, 50 minutes
and recorded it all.
I've got loads of footage, a lot
more detail, including a
bit more about what constitutes
a view.
And I know some of you
will want to see it.
I haven't had time to edit it
all just yet, but stay tuned
because I'll be uploading
that to
Numberphile in the near future.
And for those of you who don't
like these ones that are a bit
more about computers and the
internet, I'm sorry.
Numberphile's always
unpredictable, and I promise
next time it might be something
you enjoy a bit more.
MATT PARKER: How many
arrows do you want?
So the next one, let's say we
did 3 to the power of, to the
power of, oh, arrow, arrow,
arrow, or whatever you
want to call this.
3.
Will that--